to nuclear power plants this is scary
they are in the direct path of this
massive storm nine million people may
lose power joining us now Florida Power
and Light a company vice president chief
of communications Rob Gould is with us
when you go back to the last hurricane
there was a lot of damage to the nuclear
site and I guess my main question is
this is such an important issue how safe
are those sites are they able to sustain
160 mile per hour winds and more and
they're on the coast yes Shawn let me
let me set the record straight there
really was no damage to the site at all
Turkey Point which is around Homestead
Florida just south of Miami the actual
nuclear facility itself was not damaged
the eye of the storm itself went right
overhead a cat5 storm hurricane Andrew
and we had no damage to the nuclear
facilities nuclear facilities are the
the strongest in the world as far as
construction if you think about the way
they're structured we're talking about
six foot thick concrete surrounding the
entirety of the reactor itself you have
redundancy upon redundancy upon
redundancy after that but again if you
go back to the fact that we had an I go
directly over Hurricane Andrew in 1992
go over the site with Hurricane Andrew
and had no damage to the facility itself
and then I would add in 2004 our st.
Lucie site which is up in st. Lucie
County just north of West Palm Beach
we had hurricanes Francis and Jean goes
straight overhead and there were no
damage there was no damage to the
nuclear facility itself is working and
very very groundbreaking Andrew did
create a lot of damage you're saying
that there wasn't a lot of money spent
as a result of that hurricane no okay
well though these were some off-site
facilities or off off properties so to
speak but the actual nuclear reactor
itself the facility itself no damage at
all all right so we're really hoping in
that particular case you do expect
people will lose power I assume well yes
we have we've been very clear now if you
look at where we stretch
we go from the Georgia line all the way
down toward the keys and then back up
toward Tampa 90% of our customers are
within 20% excuse me 20% of our
customers are within 90 percent of our
customers are within 20 miles of the
coast line excuse me and so we are going
to see some damage for sure we've been
very clear that what we will see is not
necessarily a restoration which could
take days or hours we're talking about a
rebuild itself